Jin's in love excrement soaked
billionaires and a musical action epic
that puts the MCU to shame 2022's best
films covered every genre and proved
that Original Stories are far from dead
Athena is a thriller a family drama and
a snapshot of contemporary tensions
between citizens and institutions it's
all told from the perspective of three
grieving Brothers trying to make sense
of their fourth brother's death if the
opening sequence doesn't grab you you
may not have a pulse in a continuous
10-minute shot a press conference
regarding the brothers Murder by the
police collapses into a frenetic raid of
the station by well-organized protesters
who proceed to fortify an apartment
complex into a revolutionary stronghold
it only gets more intense from there
years after the release of his acclaimed
debut feature in Bruges writer director
Martin McDonough reunites Stars Colin
Farrell and Brandon Gleason for another
bizarre and Moody dark comedy set on a
fictional island off the coast of
Ireland in the 1920s where drinking
music and Idol chat are the only
available pastimes the Banshees of
vinisharin is the story of a messy
breakup between lifelong friends column
and Park
let's just call it quits we won't call
it quits
we call it the start witty bleakly funny
and shots on the picturesque Aaron
Islands the Banshees of innishairen is a
shoe-in for Oscar nominations for acting
writing and costume design now and then
a horror film comes along that has to be
seen to believed Barbarian is one such
movie a woman arrives at the house she's
renting for a short period of time only
to discover someone's already home now
she must spend the night sharing the
home with this stranger that's not all
the house itself seems to Harbor its own
strange Secrets equal parts shocking
revolting and hilarious Barbarian is
best enjoyed without spoilers and a room
full of likewise unsuspecting viewers
the streets of Gotham City have never
been grittier than in the Batman a new
interpretation of DC's most popular
superhero despite being yet another
reboot that takes the character Back to
Basics as a lone crime fighter chasing
gangsters and serial killers the Batman
still feels distinct from both
Christopher Nolan's nuts and bolts
realism and Tim Burton's dark Whimsy
more than any previous Batman film it's
a detective story closer to a 1970s
neo-noir than a modern action
Blockbuster within the film's ambitious
three hour run time you'll find
memorable performances gorgeous
photography and one of the most in-depth
explorations of the title character ever
to hit the big screen 2018's black
panther was a global sensation earning
over 1 billion dollars at the box office
and a slew of Academy Award nominations
including best picture as with any
successful chapter in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it seemed obvious
that black panther would expand into a
colossal fan franchise in its own right
the sudden and tragic death of star
Chadwick Boseman through the future of
the series into question but director
Ryan coogler and his cast and crew
committed themselves to reworking the
planned sequel into a heartfelt tribute
to their absent friend on top of the
familiar action adventure and spectacle
that Marvel fans have come to expect
black panther wakanda forever offers a
complex meditation on Grief following
The Lovable Ensemble from the first film
through the process of moving on after a
devastating loss Bell follows a talented
teenage songwriter suzu who's been
unable to raise her voice in songs since
the tragic death of her mother but when
she logs into the futuristic social
media platform you suzu transforms into
Belle a spellbinding songstress who
becomes a global sensation overnight as
suzu attempts to reconcile the two parts
of herself she becomes fascinated by an
Infamous online prize fighter with a
monstrous virtual Avatar Bell is
nominally an adaptation of the classic
fairy tale Beauty and the Beast for the
social media age but the film brings far
more to the table than just the familiar
beats of its source material Bell is
part Timeless and part bleeding edge
contemporary as exemplified by its two
distinct but equally beautiful art
styles painterly traditional animation
to represent the real world and
eye-popping cell-shaded CGI to represent
the virtual reality of the internet
Cooper Rife Stars opposite Dakota
Johnson in cha-cha real smooth a sweet
witty Indie comedy that took home the US
dramatic audience award at 2022's
Sundance Film Festival Rife petrays
Andrew a recent college graduate who's
landed back at his mom and stepdad's
house while he figures out the next
phase of his life though built around
the sizzling Chemistry Between Andrew
and Dakota Johnson's 30-something
character Domino Chacha real smooth is
really a quirky and heartfelt
coming-of-age story about a
college-educated young adult who has to
get a job at the Mall food court
South Korean director Park Chen wook of
old boy and the handmaiden fame presents
a seductive Thriller that expertly
balances suspense romance and comedy in
decision to leave when an ace detective
is assigned to investigate a mysterious
death he becomes bizarrely obsessed with
the victim's Widow the feeling seems to
be mutual but is the Widow simply toying
with him to cover up murder gorgeously
shot and simmering with tension that's
occasionally broken by a pitch perfect
gag decision to leave is a masterfully
crafted mystery around the turn of the
Millennium a string of teen flicks
adapting the plays of William
Shakespeare to a contemporary High
School setting debuted
Sweet Love renew thy Force hey
don't say that to me people can hear you
with do Revenge director Jennifer Caden
Robinson makes a killer case for giving
the same treatment to the films of
Alfred Hitchcock in this comedy thriller
Loosely based on Strangers on a train a
new kid at an affluent prep school and
its disgraced queen bee team up to exact
some cruel and imaginative vengeance
upon each other's enemies I want to burn
her to the ground whoa you're giving off
some serious Glenn Close and Fatal
Attraction energy Lively funny and
sporting a tremendous performance from
Maya Hawk if do Revenge doesn't spark a
new trend in high school Thrillers
someone is going to pay Emily the
criminal is a crime Thriller born of the
present moment as a generation weighed
down by debt and denied full-time
employment struggles to make ends meet
in the gig economy Aubry Plaza stars as
Emily who juggles various menial jobs
with combined wages that can't make a
dent in her student loans when presented
with the opportunity to make a lot of
money fast Emily becomes a dummy Shopper
maxing out cloned credit cards and
reselling the purchases on the black
market you know what my mistake really
was I didn't go far enough the story of
a hard luck Outlaw getting in too deep
is nothing new but Emily the criminal
has such a Modern Edge that it can't be
denied Evelyn Wang is an exhausted and
unfulfilled laundromat owner who's just
trying to get her taxes done when she's
suddenly recruited to fight in an
interdimensional War to save the
Multiverse Evelyn will have to learn how
to verse jump tapping into the feelings
memories and skills of her alternate
selves all of whom have done more with
their lives than she has everything
everywhere all at once is uproariously
funny visually dazzling and deeply
moving director Steven Spielberg has
shaped the past 50 years of Cinema more
than any other filmmaker now he's
finally ready to tell the story of the
events that shaped Steven Spielberg
though his films are generally known for
their sincerity the Fable men's is
Spielberg's most personal work yet as a
semi-autobiographical story based on his
own adolescence you do what your heart
says you have to Sammy fableman is a
young Jewish kid with a love of
filmmaking who must navigate the
collapse of his parents marriage his is
a sweet coming-of-age story that's also
a thoughtful and sympathetic examination
of 11 couples who've drawn apart from
each other Beyond this the fablemans is
a Charming love lettered Cinema
following its protagonist as he embarks
on ever more complicated home movie
projects that are a delight to see on
the big screen the latest in a proud
tradition of modernized Jane Austen
adaptations Fire Island sets Pride and
Prejudice during a tight-knit queer
chosen family's annual reunion at the
titular New York vacation spot Austin's
novel of manners translates beautifully
into this contemporary setting trading
Prim propriety for raunchy comedy while
also poking fun at the roles of race
class and narrow beauty standards in a
closed but thriving sexual economy
Conrad ricamora is a standout as will
fire Island's version of the steamy and
stoic Mr Darcy but the heart of the film
is the friendship between the lead
characters portrayed by Joel kimbuster
and Bowen yang fire of Love tells the
true story of Katya and Maurice craft
Fearless volcanologists who visited
multiple erupting volcanoes during the
latter half of the 20th century to
finance their studies the couple filmed
and photographed their Adventures
turning them into books and movies that
captivated audiences across the world
this documentary is the distillation of
hundreds of hours of footage of their
strange journey into one stunning
narrative fire of Love is part nature
documentary heart romance and part
tragedy best seen with the person next
to you clutching your hand
set in Mussolini's fascist Italy
Guillermo del Toros Pinocchio is a dark
fairy tale about childhood Parenthood
and mortality brought to life via
stunning stop-motion animation what's
most remarkable about this film is that
its family entertainment that never
panders too hard to either adults or
children there are heavy themes and
silly slapstick but neither feels like a
correction for the other Del Toro is a
grown-up with a kid's imagination
equally capable of simplifying complex
ideas and extracting the maximum
substance from storybook Concepts the
result is one of the year's best
animated features and a worthy entry in
the filmography of the oscar-winning
director in between bringing his friends
on vacation to Sunny locales around the
world Adam Sandler maintains a
successful career as a dramatic actor in
Hustle Sandler plays A desperate
basketball Scout who discovers a
world-class talent in a poor single dad
from Spain the film doesn't exactly
break this Sports drama mold but Sandler
and co-star juancho Hernan Gomez share a
lovely chemistry that reminds you how
uplifting this dying genre can be this
is all for you pal nice for us okay it's
for us the menu is the satirical
Thriller in which a dozen Discerning
diners catch a ferry ride to an
exclusive culinary experience that just
might be their last the film has a bit
of a Twilight Zone Edge to it its ironic
twists are somewhat predictable but also
hugely satisfying like a great meal it's
almost exactly what you ordered but with
a few surprising accents and secret
ingredients to make what could have been
simple sustenance into an experience
worth paying top dollar for for a tour
Jordan Peele returns with his biggest
and most ambitious film yet a sci-fi
horror comedy western that deconstructs
the very concept of filmed entertainment
when a Brother's sister pair of down
under luck horse trainer spies a UFO
above their Ranch they they hope to
secure their Legacy by capturing the
first incontrovertible proof of
extraterrestrial life but at what cost
are they willing to attain the
impossible shot and what drives people
to seek out bizarre spectacle in the
first place peel doesn't answer every
question he poses to tremendous effect
expect the wheels in your head to keep
turning for days after you see nope from
celebrated director Robert Eggers Comes
This unflinchingly brutal historical
fantasy based on the ancient Viking Epic
that inspired Shakespeare's Hamlet the
dethroned prince omelette will stop at
nothing to exact Vengeance against the
uncle who slew his father and kidnapped
his mother but will his quest leave him
more Beast than man the northmen is as
visually stunning as it is disturbing a
meticulous and unsanitized portrait of
the Grim and miserable past
pray a prequel to Predator set in the
North American Great Plains during the
18th century is by far the best
installment in the series since the
original it's a lean character-driven
horror Thriller with some gnarly
cleverly staged violence Amber mid
Thunder Makes Her mark on action Cinema
as Naru a young Comanche Warrior looking
to prove herself by hunting a dangerous
Beast her prey turns out to be a
well-armed extraterrestrial who's come
to kill humans for sport as well as the
portent of the colonizing threat that
awaits her community like all Predator
films prey can be enjoyed entirely on
its own but it also contains some cute
Easter eggs for longtime fans of the
franchise's mythology Resurrection is a
White Knuckle psychological horror film
in which star Rebecca Hall delivers one
of 2022's best performances Hall
portrays Margaret a businesswoman and
single parent who seems in total control
of her life until a mysterious man from
past resurfaces and sensor spiraling
into an all-consuming Panic what is it
that makes his mere presence so
terrifying we are absolutely not telling
you need to see this one for yourself
essentially a superhero epic based on
two real Indian revolutionaries of the
1920s who likely never actually met RR
is a violent thrilling heartfelt and
gleefully over-the-top Hollywood action
musical Blockbuster it's song and dance
number not to not to has gone Mega viral
online and it teases only a small
fraction of the bombastic excitement of
its battle scenes it's a three-hour film
that energizes rather than exhausts its
Audience by the time the credits roll
you'll feel like you could punch a hole
through the Moon
just as each scream sequel has commented
on the nature of horror sequels and the
changing landscape of horror cinema this
5th entry tackles the Contemporary trend
of The Recoil in which Legacy characters
pass the torch to a new generation but
as always scream isn't just about dorky
inside jokes for cinephiles it's also a
thrilling horror who done it in its own
right with scares and Chuckles in equal
measure scream can be enjoyed as either
a jumping on point or a satisfying
conclusion to one of Horror's most
consistent franchises
Cape Blanchette delivers one of the most
captivating performances of her career
as fictional composer conductor Lydia
tar in this gripping character study tar
is a Titan in the world of classical
music with a colossal ego to match but
in the run-up to her latest career
Milestone Whispers of her personal and
professional misconduct Crescendo into a
deafening Roar that threatens to knock
her off her Podium Blanchette endows tar
with such Charisma and Menace one can
immediately understand how awful people
manage to acquire so much power or how
power can make a person awful there are
moments when you might find yourself
sympathizing with this self-obsessed
genius even as you eagerly anticipate
her Downfall with three thousand years
of longing director George Miller has
delivered a haunting adult fairy tale
romance though unsurprisingly a box
office bomb this dark storybook tale of
a solitary academic who frees the lonely
Gin from centuries of imprisonment is
both thought-provoking and
heart-wrenching musing on the nature of
love the shape of stories and the death
of myth in our modern world it's not a
feel-good movie it's a feel everything
movie till is based on the true story of
Mamie Till's fight for justice after her
son Emmett was brutally murdered by
white supremacists at the age of 14.
till introduces us to a bright and
Charming young man in Emmett bow till
and forces us to reckon with his inhuman
death and the Deep wounds it leaves
behind not only on those who love him
but on everyone the lynching is meant to
terrorize an intimate and heartbreaking
character study it centers on a woman
whose unimaginable pain becomes the
center of a national news story and a
movement for civil rights what results
is a commanding entry to the Hollywood
main stage for both director chinoya
chukwu and star Danielle deadweiler top
gun Maverick is a ridiculously fun
Cinema attic novelty that will thrill
even the most cynical viewer issuing CGI
as much as possible director Joseph
gazinski puts the actors and cameras
right into actual fighter jets and lets
audiences Marvel at incredible real-life
Feats of aerial agility just want to
manage expectations
the spectacle is bound together by
irresistible Charisma machine Tom Cruise
reprising the role of Pete Maverick
Mitchell leading a new generation of
HotShots Into the Danger Zone writer
director Reuben oslin won his second
pomodor for triangle of sadness a wacky
satire about class disparity and the
apocalypse though its first and third
acts contain plenty of laughs it's
middle hour set on a luxury yacht
populated by sociopathic billionaires
and an exhausted staff is worth the
price of admission alone essentially a
broad gross out comedy for Art House
audiences triangle of sadness captures
the lunacy of the mega Rich it's not the
most subtle film of the year but it is
the only one that offers the thrill of
watching The Soulless Elite violently
evacuate their digestive tracks
overachieving 8th grader May Lee awakens
one morning to discover she's
transformed into a giant red panda just
as every woman in her family has for
Generations mei's Panda form emerges
whenever she experiences strong emotions
and her mother Ming expects her to Reign
it in like she did but what if May likes
being an excitable furry monster turning
red is a joyful celebration of
friendship family and how the awkward
process of growing up complicates both
the woman King is a grand Hollywood War
epic unlike any other set in 19th
century dahome it stars Viola Davis as
general naniska the leader of an elite
Army of female soldiers fight
or we die
Through The Eyes of nuniska and teenage
recruit naui the woman King explores the
lives of these incredible Warriors as
their Nation attempts to divest itself
from the monstrosity of the slave trade
between its taught Direction gnarly
action and heartfelt performances it's a
Prestige Blockbuster that kicks butt
while celebrating a piece of History
Hollywood has traditionally failed to
represent
laughs